-Charlie! -Jimmy.
-Good to see you, bud. Thanks for being on the show.
Congrats on the new album, bud. You got some bops on there.
-Thank you. "Bops." -I love it.
My favorite jam right now is --
♪ You turn me on like a light switch ♪
[ Fingers snap ] Charlie?!
-[ Glass shatters ] -Jimmy, I'm over here.
-Where?! -Here.
[ Crashing ] -Here?
-Literally right here. -Let me grab your hand!
-Jimmy, that's not my hand. -I'm so sorry.
[ Glass shatters ] Ohh!
-Where's the walls?!
-Feel for a wall! Help! Help us!
I think I'm bleeding! I can feel myself bleeding!
-Jimmy, Jimmy, calm down. Just stay where you are.
Let me try something. [ Clears throat ]
♪ You turn me on like a light switch ♪
[ Fingers snap ] -[ Gasps ] Ohh.
I wasn't bleeding! I was just pouring water in my hand!
-Okay, then. You're good? -Yep. Let's get started.
See you out there.
[ Thud ] Ow!